не совість не прийдуть на вас
підігрівання так здається на porsche
повалять холодно сам від неї більше тварюки
не знаєш council
адже ще тут живуть навчилася виживати
і наприклад за рахунок розведення тварин
in a loner ства для тутешніх основ
рідка культура регіонального та ви
адже вирішила дати сотні тисяч 2 ринку
забій будуть будова не спеціальної суперечки
до забою панікує навантажений авто
газових компаній
наш президент має знати наш президент
повинен знати ще ми я ще ми теж люди
у чому інші шоу очі та холоді можемо
прибрати його ти
червоною продукцію нашого розвиватися та
продукції нашого розвивати місяці віпі
дози рю ще за планом та влада
приковують і бізнес-інтереси газпром
вигадуючи хаосу районі вул і не лиж і
заражають теж регоче сунуть і поважаю
тикові забою лінії так масштабний забій
гол і не всі плану нитки на ямалі шалено
трагедія і для людей, і для тварин
тварин і для оленярів кого лайнері
їх витрачаєте таку кількість з полином cq рот
кита armenchik
на ведена проходить і ми забити я буду
тут у нього є компенсації як буде
здійснюватися компенсації за багато
полином і
самого корму всі запаси ви витрачаю на
кожну рядів ти на ямалі та за малий
дахід нам це спа ну-ка ти наших
лайнерів до інтенсивного вокаліст onew
аланню
за будинком, щоб за менше угу
поваливши я
господар від прямого більше продукції
видно і більше фінансового шукав
близько 3 євро відривають панове ризою
кілограм оленя тіни протест проти
освіченого забою худорлявості набираю
звернув президенту путіну dvd c у працю
це ситуацію адаптацію оленя риф на
дозі продадуть до Москви